next on american history tv author david
wetzel talks about his book the
vanishing messiah the life and
resurrections of francis slaughter the
author describes the mysteries
surrounding the 19th century faith
healer who reportedly cured thousands of
ailing people on the american frontier
before he disappeared from denver in
1895.
the kansas city public library hosted
this event it's about an hour and 10
minutes
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
i'm crosby kemper the director of the
kansas city public library and we
welcome you to our uh
lecture today on the vanishing messiah
and actually i'm here uh to talk to you
about two vanishing messiahs uh david
wetzel will be here in a minute
introduced by eli paul talking about uh
francis schlatter the the vanishing
messiah of the 19th century i want to
mention one thing about the vanishing
messiah of the 21st century our own eli
paul eli came to us five years ago
from his extraordinary efforts in
creating the national world war one
museum at liberty memorial
he's been here for five years and has
done a remarkable job uh as the director
of the
missouri valley room and our special
collections at the library he's overseen
the missouri valley sundays of which
this is a part
great presentations on local history in
our missouri valley region
he's developed incredible collections
that have come to the library he's a
magnet for collecting uh in kansas city
and in our region he is a great
professional historian he's overseen uh
tremendous exhibitions that we've put on
you've seen our shakespeare exhibit
which is up today wounded knee of which
he is himself a historian
etc etc he's done a fabulous job but
unfortunately he is going to retire now
to write books so he this is almost his
swan song i'm not going to be here next
week for the next missouri valley sunday
uh where on the day of his retirement
i'll be on vacation so i wanted to do a
shout out today
to a great historian a great leader of
our special collections and our local
history efforts uh and a wonderful man
and uh he will now come up and introduce
our speaker today eli paul
thank you
thank you crosby for those very kind
words and welcome
to the kansas city public library on a
beautiful missouri valley sunday my name
is eli paul and i head up the special
collections department which is
headquartered just down the way
in the nearby missouri valley room our
program is made possible today by
generous grant
from the national endowment for the
humanities
and it is
my pleasure to present david wetzel the
author of the new and intriguingly
entitled book the vanishing messiah the
life and resurrections of francis
schlatter
this is a fascinating tale of religion
and religious belief in the american
west and although these events played
out more than a century ago i think the
story possesses elements that still
resonate today picture this an anonymous
figure suddenly enters the public arena
and almost immediately and magically
captures the attention of the nation
many of those citizens in retrospect may
have been gullible but they did possess
some unfulfilled needs that this
character filled
we all have witnessed such a phenomenon
without naming names
nevertheless
in these types of tales how many of the
characters just as suddenly and
literally vanish
this happened with
the disappearing faith healer of the
west
david has doggedly tracked down the
story and has unraveled much of the
mystery and maybe no other scholar could
have done this
david comes from and knows the region
where schlatter performed his miracles
he recently retired from the colorado
historical society in denver after 26
years as a writer historian editor and
director of the society's publications
programs he knows the history today he
lives just a few blocks away from this
library and is an active supporter of
the special collections
so it is with great pleasure that we
have him here to talk about his new book
please welcome david wetzel
[Applause]
thank you eli
i i prefer being kind of informal but
with a figure who is
unknown virtually
uh and with the amount of information i
have to give i'm gonna
be a little more formal than i normally
would be
so if you'll bear with me
it was almost exactly 120 years ago
today that the world's
first that the world first discovered
francis slaughter
he was found wandering from village to
village in the rio grande valley south
of albuquerque
he wore ragged ill-fitting clothes he
had long flowing hair
and a thick beard and on his swollen
feet he wore an old pair of shoes whose
tops have been cut from the soles
you'll see a picture of that
people like francis schlotter could be
found everywhere
wandering the roads and railroad tracks
of the west in the mid 1990s
they were the homeless of that area era
of economic depression but slaughter was
different
rumor passed from village to village
that he had raised a child twice from
the dead
only to lose it a third time
then came reports that he had healed a
number of villagers simply by the power
of his touch
reporters from the albuquerque morning
democrat
went out in search of him
along
along the way they found firsthand that
these reports were true
juliano cedillo who had been paralyzed
in both arms for 16 years
was out working in the fields jesus
velasquez
blind for three years could now see
and when reporters finally caught up
with slaughter in the town of pajarito
they were astounded to discover
how much this man reminded them of the
biblical image of christ
when they interviewed him they learned
that he was 39 years old that he was a
lifelong catholic and that he was the
native of alsace france
he had been in the united states for
many years working as a cobbler
in 1892 his travels took him to denver
where he worked as a shoemaker for
several months
at that time clean shaven and earnest
i'll give you clean shave and earnest
slaughter had taken an interest in both
healing and in the spiritualist movement
those who believe that communication
with the dead was possible
one day at his cobbler's bench a voice
came to him out of nowhere telling him
to ride a friend back east whose arm was
paralyzed slaughter doubted what he
heard but the voice came again
then he obeyed again and wrote the
letter and later learned that his
friend's paralysis had been healed that
was the beginning of his mission to go
forth and heal through prayer
in july 1893 at the behest of the divine
voice
schlatter gave up his shoemaker's
business and all his possessions
and set out on a journey that would take
him three thousand miles around the west
all of it on foot
he traveled east across the colorado
plains
beginning in denver with the blue line
across colorado plains to kansas city
stayed there for only a few hours
keeping in line of the
on the line of the railroads and at
kansas city he turned south into
present-day oklahoma he followed the
direction he followed no direction of
his own he was
moving
solely at the voice and direction of the
father
along the way schlatter argued bitterly
with the father when it commanded him to
beg for food or shelter by the way the
father the voice the master in some
cases all refer to god of course in this
case
or to walk an additional five miles
after an exhausting day but he always
lost these arguments
the cobbler always lost these arguments
for the purpose of the journey was to
chasten his human will
so that he could become an instrument of
the father
in hot springs arkansas the farthest
point east in his journey slaughter was
arrested for vagrancy and thrown in jail
he remained there for five months the
victim of brutality by other prisoners
and of exploitation by his jailers
but it was here near the end of his
incarceration that he had a vision which
foretold a far greater destiny for him
than he had realized before
he would continue in his preparation to
be a healer but the father's plan
encompassed much much more
with this vision before him slaughter
escaped the hot springs jail and turned
west in his pilgrimage
the second part of his journey
uh proved even more of an ordeal in the
first he suffered privation exposure and
danger as he walked across texas new
mexico and arizona to southern
california
twice he was robbed and once threatened
with death
yet through all of this he held fast to
his mission and obeyed the commandments
of the father
finally when he arrived in puentes now
part of los angeles
he had achieved the spiritual strength
to begin healing here for for a time he
remained and performed cures on the
indians of the san jacinto valley
probably his first cure first attempts
at healing
then he took what small funds he had
accumulated bought a boat ticket that's
why there's no
line going from san diego to san
francisco and went by boat to san
francisco from there began another
arduous trek down the sacramento valley
and across
the mojave desert with nothing but
a
flower and water to new mexico
it was this bedraggled spiritually
chastened man that reported his life
into the figure of christ in the summer
of 1895.
and they were not far wrong
for when a minister asked slaughter if
indeed he were the christ
the healer answered i am
soon after slaughter arrived in new
mexico he began a 40-day fast it was to
be the culmination
of his preparation to become a healer
toward the end of july when this
photograph was taken
in albert in an albuquerque studio he
looked pale thin and wand he stood
approximately five feet like nine inches
in height
though he impressed reporters at being
as being much much taller he had
extraordinarily large hands and when he
was in good health
he had a massive build largely due to
strenuous exercising and much of that
due to the fact that he
came west initially because he was
suffering from tuberculosis
from this time on he remained in
albuquerque a guest of prominent
residents
in the city's old town
as he continued his fast he treated
greater numbers of people and spoke with
reporters from newspapers across the
west the reporters also took
testimonials from people he treated and
his reputation as a christ-like healer
spread across the nation
one of the people who came to see him
was edward l fox
a denver coal and grain merchant and
former city alderman fox brought with
him a friend and neighbor henry
hallenstein who was nearly blind and
schlatter gave howenstein special
treatments after regular days
after the regular day sessions had ended
fox was so impressed with what he saw
that he invited schlatter to visit
denver and to carry on his mission of
healing there to a greater and greater
crowd
at first reluctant schlatter agreed to
return to the city where he had begun
his pilgrimage two years before but did
so when fox
said he would pay for his train fare
first however
slaughter had to complete his fast
this he did with a huge meal
a couple of weeks later a meal that
astounded those who witnessed it
now listen to this after having taken
nothing but water for 40 days schlatter
sat down to a supper of 11 fried eggs
nine slices of salt pork with gravy
seven pieces of cheese
two tablespoons tablespoons of chili
clean carne three helpings of pickled
apples a slice of ripe eight slices of
rye bread three pieces of roast chicken
a slice of cake
a cup of coffee and four glasses of port
wine
people expected him to drop dead on the
spot but a doctor who monitored his
pulse throughout the meal
found that it remained normal
a week later schlatter said goodbye to
his albuquerque host and took the train
to denver
he had survived the fast-ending meal but
was very ill and weak
all along his route of travel people in
small towns gathered at the depots to be
touched by him
but because he didn't have the strength
to go to them
he began taking their handkerchiefs and
this was the first time
really this had been done and
so far as i know in the 19th century or
in the modern era he took their
handkerchiefs held them in his hands and
returned them
he maintained that the father's power to
cure them would be just as effective
this way
as by his own hands
when he arrived in denver on august 23rd
1895 slaughter went into a retreat for
three weeks and refused to see the
public but talk to occasional reporters
then after that time he went to the fox
home
and uh was boarded by
edward fox fox's wife marion daughter
annie
and a nephew leonard kern this is a very
small home and there were four people
already living there and they introduced
this stranger into their home and gave
them their
their
personal bed
the fox home was located in the hot
located in the highlands area of north
denver not far from fox's coal and grain
business across the south platte river
september 16
was the day that had been announced for
slaughter to begin the healing sessions
at the fox home
and 300 people were waiting when he
emerged at nine o'clock in the morning
within two days that number had climbed
several fold the size of the crowds took
fox completely by surprise
as did the shoving and jostling to get
to the healer
so fox quickly built a guard rail
parallel to his picket fence so that
people had to move single file past the
spot where slaughter stood
almost as many people came to watch as
to be treated
up and down the smaller street you could
see carriages long lines of people
waiting for treatment
and very shortly after opening day
vendors of sandwiches coffee lemonade
peanuts and watermelon
the vendors and hawkers lent a festive
atmosphere to the healing sessions but
the crowds
were full of solemn curious and
suffering people
his routine at the fox home didn't vary
he began his healing sessions at nine
o'clock in the morning and quit
at three in the afternoon when he would
go to out to the carriages and treat the
people who were too sick or disabled to
come to him
he had a curious method of grasping each
person that came to him he would take
their right hand in his left and left
hand in his right crossways
and then utter a short prayer to the
father at first he would spend a minute
or two with each person but as the
crowds grew greater he would often treat
three or four people a minute and then
often more frequently
when news got around that schlatter
could heal for the medium of
handkerchiefs or letters people in line
began bringing
in their handkerchiefs or and those that
belong to their relatives and friends
people who lived out of town at night
schlatter would serve what aunt would
sit and answer
hundreds of letters that came to him
each day but these began to pile up so
high that he could not keep up with them
they filled nearly an entire room in a
small in the small house
i have a picture of bundles of mail but
it's not very good
this happens to be the first
letter
healing order that schlatter sent out to
come to light
i expect that it'll be others
the healer offered treatment to everyone
no matter what their age
social status race or ethnic background
all he required of anyone was that they
have faith in the power of the father to
heal him in fact he was so universal in
offering his gifts of healing
that some claimed he was a fraud for the
sole reason that he didn't require a
confession of faith as the holiness
people or later pentecostal people
did when they were performing healing
acts
meanwhile the crowds grew larger
they jumped from an average of one
thousand people a day to two thousand or
three thousand
long lines sometimes three abreast
snaked around the block
and passed down several more blocks
trolley cars ran all day long bringing
new arrivals
from denver's hotels to the fox home
there was good reason for this
slaughter had announced back in
september that he would be leaving
denver for chicago on november 16th
this is a rubio act here
as the days of his ministry came to a
close more and more sufferers who came
to see him were from out of state so in
the last days of schlatter's ministry
everyone was desperate to see the healer
before he left town
the hotels were packed
union station was described as looking
like a hospital
and street
and people were sitting up all night
long to get an early place in line
pardon me
on the 13th of november a wednesday the
crowd numbered 5 000 people
this was the last day that schlatter was
in denver and this picture was taken the
caption reads last hour
but the photographer didn't know that
when he took that picture and he put in
the caption later on
then suddenly without warning slaughter
was gone two days before his scheduled
departure
when the excitement of his ministry was
at its peak he disappeared
as an early crowd of 500 gathered in
front of the fox home on that gray
morning of november 14th all they saw
was a sign posted on the front porch
it read
the healer is gone we know not where as
the news spread it created shock anger
outrage and grief
hundreds had traveled to denver to see
the healer
those ex
those expectations have been shattered
and these people felt bitterly uh
betrayed
inside the home
edward fox explained to reporters what
he knew of schlatter's disappearance
he had knocked on the healer's bedroom
door at seven o'clock that morning he
said and got no response
slaughter was normally a light sleeper
so fox tried a few more times and then
entered the room
on the bed he found a note pinned to the
pillow
it read mr fox my mission is finished
father takes me away goodbye
in fact however
as i show in my book
the note
was a deception edward fox knew very
well where the healer was as did
slaughter's close supporters
they had joined him in a conspiracy to
get him out of town so that uh he could
be on his way before any reporters and
rumor hunters found out about it
at 10 the previous night fox had asked
his nephew
leonard kern
to hitch a horse to his buggy and bring
it out of the carriage house behind the
home
leonard was also to bring a heretofore
unknown white horse named butte
fox and slaughter got into the buggy
shielded by
you know a robe and the cover of the
buggy
and drove past the crowds
uh kearns climbed on the horse the white
horse behind them and followed them out
of town the party rode 10 miles along
cherry creek to the south
east
and there slaughter mounted the horse
and continued on his journey while fox
went back to tell the crowd that
the healer disappeared and he knew
nothing about it
nearly two months and 700 miles 700
miles later the horse and rider stopped
at a ranch on a snowy january night in
daedal in the dale mountains of new
mexico 150 miles south
west of albuquerque
when the owner aydah morley saw him she
was stunned she knew very well who he
was for she had stood in the lines in
october
to receive his touch and had told her
daughter that what she felt
was an illumination
morley was the daughter of a legendary
civil railroad engineer william raymond
morley who had built the santa fe
railroad over the rugged raton pass
between colorado and new mexico a
university educated woman she had built
a substantial house
in what
in what was became known as white house
canyon and it was an oasis of culture
music and thought in the wilds of
western new mexico
her three grown children away at college
when the healer arrived but she was not
alone for a cook and several cow hands
looked after her
slaughter told morley
that the father had directed him to her
ranch for a period of rest and retreat
from the world
when she recovered from her shock she
invited him in and the healer became a
guest in her home for the next three
months
during that time he and his hostess as
morley called herself
had long conversations about religion
politics economics
and social issues
morley discovered that unlike the simple
cobbler with a gift for healing that
slaughter had been made out to be
he had an impressive wealth of learning
and could speak knowledgeably on almost
any subject
he had once been a populist and had
agitated for political reform now he
believed that the gulf between the rich
and the poor had become so large that
the world was heading for a great
revolution and it wouldn't be a human
revolution
the father he told
slaughter told
morley was planning to destroy the rich
powerful and privileged of all the
nations
in short schlatter said the world was
heading toward an apocalypse
a war of desolation foretold in the book
of daniel
the father had called on slaughter to be
the messiah of a new age that would
blossom around the globe in the wake of
this destruction
it would be the new jerusalem
a millennial order under god and its
namesake city
new jerusalem would lie in the daedal
mountains of new mexico
this was slaughter said the meaning of
his vision in hot springs two years
earlier and his three thousand mile walk
of humiliation suffering and privation
um it had been a walk he said for all
humanity
in fact
slaughter convicted uh confided and
morally he was a reincarnation of jesus
christ sent to the world this time
not with love but a sword
over the next few months as the world
approached the 20th century violence and
social disorder would prevail up to the
year 1899 when the words of daniel would
be fulfilled
in the meantime the father had directed
slaughter to go even further into
retreat to lose himself in the wilds of
old mexico
at the proper time he would emerge as
god's appointed leader over a universal
utopia of peace democracy equality and
prosperity
adam morley believed him the
conversation she had with him convinced
her that he was the reincarnated messiah
or very close to it
she implored him to write everything
down about his two-year pilgrimage and
when his difficulties with the english
language grew too great she took his
dictation
the world she believed was uh must know
of his sac of the sacrifices on its
behalf
she also wrote down their conversations
and when the time came for him to depart
she asked him if he would if she could
publish it he agreed
and gave it the title
that
she
used the life of the harp and the hand
of the harper
this was to be a gospel of the new age
when slaughter left the morley ranch in
late march 1896 ada walked with him for
a mile or so and they said the lord's
prayer together
she was very much afraid for him
but he assured her that the father would
watch over him then he said
you will have what will seem to be
certain evidence of my death brought to
you
the world will laugh at you for
rejecting but reject it
i shall not be dead
i will return to daedal wait for me
he never saw her she never saw him again
over the next few months morley worked
on her book
at the ranch then finished it
in denver during the spring and summer
of 1897
it was published in july
but just two weeks before that news came
out of mexico
that rendered the gospel of new
jerusalem
obsolete the healer was dead
news reports stated that an american
prospect american
prospecting party for four men from el
paso
in the state of chihuahua mexico had
come across a skeleton resting against a
tree high up in the mountains its bones
bleached white and fully articulated at
the top of the canyon
a neat pile of clothing lay next to it
along with a bible
a spanish english dictionary a memo book
with the name of ayda morley on one of
its pages and a solid copper rod
shaped like a baseball bat that had been
known to
be associated with the healer
aydah morley had two reasons
then to doubt the reports first
she knew as an experienced rancher
that
uh freshly dead creatures in the wild
either human or
animal
uh do not last long in the midst of
coyotes wolves and buzzards nor do whole
skeletons survive untouched
second
she remembered slaughter's last words
and that she was to ignore any
uh evidence of his death so she made
plans to go to mexico
and see for herself and she was a
dedicated woman
she came back convinced
that slaughter was alive or at least did
not die
at the top of that canyon everyone knew
she later said that schlatter had two
missing upper teeth
and the skull she examined there had a
full set
morley believed
that
slaughter had indeed been at the spot
but had received a call from god to
abandon his possessions
and follow god's leading to another
place
did not however have the answer for the
present presence of an unknown skeleton
probably disinterred from a nearby
cemetery
or that the entire tableau
spoke of a conspiracy to make it appear
that the healer had died there
in spite of her investigation no one
believed her not even her children
still she waited for the final days that
slaughter told her would come in 1899
and she earnestly believed in his return
but as time went on she began to have
doubts in september of 1899 she wrote
the allotted days of daniel
will have been numbered by november
unless i again
take a wrong basis from which to compute
and how many people have the wrong basis
to compute
biblical
i am sure
slaughter has spoken the truth he
repeatedly told me he could not would
not die and i'm very sure he will
fulfill those words
then she said i am anxious to see that
great day for mankind it will be
glorious for his powers will be vast
enough to adjust wrongs and oppression
up to the time of her death in 1917
aydah morley must have wondered
endlessly about the healer
she obviously knew that the glorious day
that they had both hoped for hadn't
arrived
nor believed in time that it ever would
but what about francis schlatter
she had to have wondered about his fate
if slaughter did not die in mexico
as he told morley he would not
where did he
go one possibility is that he dropped
out of sight altogether
tired of everything in his life and
career
but given his devotion to god i doubted
that
on the other hand if you try to fulfill
the demands of the father and love uh
live up to his great destiny
where would that have taken him
my book the vanishing messiah looks at
just that possibility
it involves my discovery of a
remarkable
but forgotten book in the library of
congress called modern miracles of
healing
a true account of the life works and
wanderings of francis slaughter
most remarkable of all its author was
purportedly francis schlatter himself
and the book was published in 1903.
the question i faced or that anyone
would face
is whether the author of modern miracles
is an imposter or the real healer
as i found out
he wants to find out it's a simple
question to pose but a very complex
question to answer
modern miracles can be divided into
three parts first there is a story of
the healer's version of his early life
the healer of who's the author of modern
miracles and his early life
next comes a description of francis
schlatter's known career beginning with
his emergence in new mexico in 1895 and
ending with his departure from eden
morley's ranch in 1896. last there's the
story of francis schlatter the author
after he leaves aydah morley's ranch
until the present time that is 1903.
so let's begin at the beginning i want
to try the beginning of this book a
schlatter of martin martin modern
miracles offers a fantastic fantastical
account of his early life
he says his alsatian parents
brought the two-year-old francis to
america in 1858 and settled in columbia
tennessee
in fact documents show that francis
schlatter's french alsatian parents
both died in 1870 and 1871
and leaving leaving him an orphan at age
14.
then
modern miracles author writes in 1868
his his
his alsatian father dies and his mother
marries an english
englishman named edward martin
later still francis gets uncomfortable
because the tennessee friends he has
teased him about his psychic powers and
he returns to europe for many years
returning in 1884
where he picks up the life of the known
francis slaughter
that's the early life now let's for a
minute skip over the known career and go
directly to the years after his
departure from ada morley's ranch
modern miracles schlatter says that his
beloved horse butte after he left adam
morley's ranch drained alcoholic water
and died on the way to mexico
the healer in his grief over his loss
abandons his journey to mexico and makes
his way to the upper reaches of the ohio
uh river valley and starts a walk down
the ohio and mississippi rivers like
another pilgrimage
this is in the summer
of 1896 just a few weeks after he leaves
at a morley's ranch
now all of this would have remained just
a made-up story
if he hadn't mentioned in modern
miracles that he was admitted to good
samaritan hospital in cincinnati on his
journey
for treatment of an injury
and as it turned out i checked good
samaritan hospital in cincinnati and
they had records from that period of
time
they had a patient record book from from
that time and earlier
not knowing what i would find i took a
two week trip to follow the healer of
modern miracles and stop by good
samaritan on my journey
it took me a while of looking through
the record books but
here's what i found
the patient
named johnny martin born to louisa
martin in columbia tennessee
had begun
on the surface a career as an impostor
of francis slaughter
in 1896
or shortly thereafter
later i found census records from
england showing that louisa martin
had given birth to a john martin in 1859
and
and other census records show that the
family went from england to canada
and in 1882 or so
they moved to columbia tennessee so
there was a there was a
census
a historical record of the of the course
of this family going to tennessee
my question was why would um john martin
in good samaritan hospital 1896
why not simply say he was from england
born in england
it's a small small
discrepancy but it made me wonder
what if it wasn't john martin in good
samaritan hospital
i would later become francis schlatter
but francis slaughter who took the name
john martin
while he was trying to
lie low in essence after his deception
in mexico
he made he
may have needed time to
kind of gather his wits
the vanishing messiah looks at my
struggle over the answer
to that question in it i propose a
hypothesis that begins with the idea
that schlatter meant exactly what he
told ada morley
that he would return in 1899 to
establish new jerusalem and why he
decided to take up his mission of
healing again under his own name when he
could have easily
if he faked his death could easily have
weathered the father's call
from a quiet the quiet obscurity of a
mexican village
why come back in other words in this
respect it's important to note that
slaughter believed deeply in his mission
and that his eyes were focused
directly on the father's promise of the
new jerusalem to come not on what
happened to him in the world of the
present in other words slaughter didn't
care for the world of mammon as he saw
it
or as it saw him either
but only for the glorious world of new
jerusalem as its people would regard him
in hindsight
after 1899
he was destined after all to be its
messiah
so if you will
i'd like to look at the history of the
posthumous francis slaughter
and make a case for why he would return
to face skepticism scorn
and rejection
i'd ask you to
to
hold and advance your skepticism while i
while i present this hypothesis
this slaughter's first national moment
of
attention took place in cleveland ohio
on june 8 1897. this was two days after
news came out of mexico that the gila
was dead
he and her friend sat down to breakfast
in a boarding house
where other boarders were discussing the
breaking news story
martin's friend turned to the group and
said
that's very clear i was under the
impression that schlatter is still very
much alive
in fact he is here with us
allow me to introduce to you francis
slaughter
in fact through the months and years
that followed
the man who had spent a few days in good
samaritan hospital never used any other
name but francis slaughter
in time he let his hair grow longer
slowly and cultivated a substantial
flowing beard slowly
just like the original healers
and it seemed as if he were growing into
the part
he had the healer's blue-gray eyes stood
the same height
and had the same large hands that
grasped his patients crosswise as the
healer had done
all something he could have certainly
known from newspaper articles
but
especially
in
the wake of the
uh schlatter's death in the news being
so fresh in people's minds
the new slaughter faced skepticism doubt
and heavy scrutiny
from reporters and city officials in
chicago in particular
the tribune enlisted a number of
denverites who compared it to francis
slaughter one witness said that the
original healer was nothing but
a slob of a dutchman and he spoke with a
strong german accent
well a new while the new healer seemed
to be to them more refined better
dressed
and uh and more uh elegant in speech and
appearance
others recalled that schlatter's hands
were rough the original sliders hands
were rough and peasant-like while the
new healers were long-fingered and
tapered
the chicago tribune reporter spoke in
particular about the air of falsity in
the posthumous healer
there is a visible attempt to act up to
his role the reporter wrote at times he
assumed dignity is dropped the far away
look in which he attempts to hold
which he attempts to hold disappears and
the divine healer becomes an
unprepossessing and commonplace looking
man
surveying with indifferent contempt the
crowds of the afflicted he is
victimizing
the healer in fact seemed to demonstrate
that very arrogance
when another skeptic skeptic asked him
if you were the christ as the minister
had in albuquerque of the original
healer
this schleider said
i am not a christ the christ was a
slaughter
almost everything he did went contrary
to what one would have would expect of
an imposter
in fact the new healer seemed intent
on making himself the anti-slaughter and
in doing it in a self-conscious way
it made me wonder francis schlatter had
warned adam morley that false prophets
would arise in his name but that she
should ignore them that prediction had a
100 accuracy rate
because he
could very well have been that false
prophet
this healer he said
pardon me
after carrying his healing message
his healing ministry throughout the
midwest and eastern united states
the healer and his manager went to
atlanta and then to birmingham along the
way reporters had noted some of his
characteristics both negative and
positive
one suggested sneeringly that he had
used that he and his manager were
effeminate another said that schlatter
seemed to speak with a peculiar twang
that was somewhat pleasing to the year
in georgia the analanda constitution
gathered witnesses as the chicago
tribune had done in chicago
and one of the witnesses they um spoke
to
unlike most of them who discounted this
this fraud
said that he had seen schlatter in
denver in 1895 and he'd noted an almost
imperceptible mark on the right side of
the healer's nose
this man the atlanta healer he said had
the very same mark
the comment went largely unnoticed but
no one at the time could have known that
a canton ohio woman who had moved to
denver in 1895 had written back home
that year
and given a rare detailed physical
description of the healer which meant
mentioned a small mark on the side of
his nose
the atlanta healer then turned to
birmingham alabama in what became his
last great healing ministry for there
there he met and
married a woman named laverna comer who
had been a healer in her own right and
was considered
a rival of schlatters in 1895.
she lived in chicago but was visiting
her hometown of birmingham within days
of their first meeting slaughter
proposed to her and they were married
secretly in coleman alabama he never
returned to birmingham to his manager or
anyone else the two of them
got married went on a honeymoon and
became a
healing team that wandered around the
country they did however
although they were successful in this
their marriage began to
deteriorate very quickly within nine
months of it in the fall of 1899
laverne's husband threatened to jump out
of the six-story window of their home in
chicago's palmer house
what led to this suicide that is unknown
but it was uh preamble to a pattern of
erratic behavior and drunkenness that
plagued their marriage from then on
again and again they fought and
separated
then returned to continue their healing
ministry but an episode in new york city
in 1901
led to a severe crisis in their marriage
police were called to their apartment
and they found leverna with her eyes
blackened packing her bags and her
drunken husband raving that he was the
messiah
she had him committed to saint elizabeth
elizabeth's hospital in washington dc
but when doctors there found him to be
sane she
and released him
luverna fled back to new york city
he followed her there and in stalking
her he was arrested and committed to a
workhor workhouse on blackwell's island
the jailers cut his hair and beard and
when he learned that laverne had taken
out divorce papers
he lost all hope on his release he
wandered aimlessly from town to town but
nobody paid attention to him
they used to think i looked like christ
he said
and that gave them faith
now with my hair gone and my wife gone
and the lawyer's notification of divorce
proceedings
i'm a broken man
luverne's friends and family had long
told her she had married an imposter but
she
had not listened to them
and insisted that he was um
he was he was authentic however his
behavior to her in new york led her to
the point of actually leaving him for
good as a last measure however she
traveled to denver and met with mary fox
who had come to know francis schlotter
well so she went back to denver
she met with mary
they had a conversation
which no one will ever know
about but luverna returned from denver
to her husband
with her faith renewed in the fact that
he was the real francis slaughter
she proposed at that time something new
that he write his autobiography and
prove to the world that he was the real
francis slaughter
he agreed and in february 1903
he produced the book we've been talking
about
modern miracles of healing it was an
effort to prove himself
as part of the book's launch the couple
announced that schlatter
would return to denver and address his
critics
casting aside the lingering doubts about
his
authenticity
he never showed up
in hindsight we can see why the man who
wrote modern miracles did not attempt
to return to denver
jubilantly and the evidence is in the
book itself
modern miracles is a remarkable book in
many respects but one of its
distinguishing features is that it
undermines the three key words in its
title a true account
truth and falsehood vi with each other
in this book
like yin and yang
and they embrace each other in the same
way mary fox said of francis schlatter
he was one of the purest of men
but there was cunning in him
that same dichotomy is apparent
throughout modern miracles but no more
than in this respect
its author gave a description of his
pilgrimage around the west
that defied all reason
while the original slaughter
had followed a
path that was guided by the father
mutter miracles
uh
root was anywhere it looked like the the
wanderings of a drunken man
and yet there is a more subtle piece of
evidence in modern miracles that
suggests this author was not a native
speaker of english
bits of odd phrasing
idiomatic expressions foreign to the
english tongue
and what one link was called an
interference of german
appears here and there
quite unconsciously
in the book
francis schlatter spent hours and days
studying english but never quite
mastered it
either in terms of structure or accent
many questions remain about the identity
of the man from good samaritan hospital
and many things can be said both pro and
con about the physical and behavioral
characteristics of francis schlatter and
john martin aka francis schlatter
but here's a
hypothesis and elaboration of the
hypothesis that i find plausible i call
it the daniel hypothesis
slaughter based his prophecy of
armageddon on the book of daniel and in
daniel chapter 9 verses 24 to 27
a series of weeks amounting to about two
and a half years precedes the war of
desolation
that daniel speaks of during this time
according to the king james version
messiah shall be cut off but not for
himself
slaughter might well have interpreted
this passage to mean that he would
supposedly die
go into hiding
and return at the proper time in 1899
to establish new jerusalem
in the interim between
1897 and 1899
he would be living in a kind of
suspended state in terms of the way he
might have thought about it
not able to reclaim his identity as the
original healer
but also not ready for his divine
personhood
at the beginning of new jerusalem the
best way to play that part perhaps was
to become a false prophet
in the dying corrupt world of the
present while laying out a history of
foreign abuse
and disbelief to show the people of new
jerusalem what he had suffered as he had
walked in the footsteps of christ
and then in the space of
a few months in 1899 the messiah's
entire vision collapsed
nothing earth shattering occurred that
year
the only wars at the turn of the century
were the boer war in south africa and
the american action in the philippines
against insurgents
the war through that some believed to
have been armageddon
world war one was still 15 years in the
future
everything slaughter prophesied in the
life of the harp had come to not
and he was left with nothing but the
damning evidence of his stage death in
mexico
thus
he had to disassociate himself from the
great healer and messiah of denver
nothing in modern miracles even hints
of the book of daniel the war of
desolation to come
or the new jerusalem
yet slaughter's intelligence even in the
improvisational act of dictating his
book to a friend
allowed him to chart a narrow course
between truth and falsehood that kept
his current loyal cur current followers
loyal while assuring his old supporters
in the west
including ada morley
that the messiah was indeed dead
of course he didn't return to denver
not because he would have been shown to
be an imposter
but because his deceit might well have
been exposed in his reputation as a
healer forever
ruined
the last 20 years of slaughter's life
were marked by
continuing troubles in his marriage
including an
actual divorce and remarriage two year
three year or two later and periods in
which slaughter gave up healing to try
his hand at other things
but only to return to his true calling
he never gave up his devotion to
spiritualism or this habit of wandering
off for weeks and months at a time which
he and laverne called god's leading
in fact
leverna found herself desperately
searching for her husband in 1922
when she had learned that he had died in
a st louis rooney house with an unknown
woman who disappeared as soon as a local
doctor came to tend the dying man the
woman was most likely a spiritualist
nurse who had been taking care of him
but the scandal led luverna
on arriving in st louis to accuse the
strange woman of murder
a coroner's report the next day
concluded that the man had died of this
an acute condition of pulmonary
tuberculosis
laverna was then outraged because her
husband's body had not been embalmed and
he was therefore unable to bring himself
back to life
luverna left st louis with instructions
to bury her husband in miamisburg ohio
where they had lived for a time
but something went wrong
his body remained in the plight funeral
home unburied for the next 25 years
discovered with other unburied bodies in
1945
it went into a common grave in the
municipal cemetery
and years later was removed with the
other unknowns
to mount lebanon cemetery
west of saint louis
on what used to be
eastern avenue
francis francis schlatter told people in
1895 that he would disappear and return
in a different form
i contend that when he left ada morley's
ranch he walked out of history as one of
the greatest healers of the 19th century
only to return as a counterfeit of
himself
that was his destiny and his personal
tragedy
i thank you
[Applause]
i can't walk around now
we do have microphones available for
your questions i'll start off david uh
can you tell us anything about the you
know what
class or ethnic
lines were followed with his followers i
mean were they of a particular type of
of
they were all over
there were there were
social lights in denver who went to see
him and wrote about it
there were people who were at that time
of course it was the height of the
economic depression following the
silver crisis
silver crash of 1892
there were homeless people
they were they were all of all classes
and types
there was a
german family who um i wrote about uh
brought beer and sandwiches to eat uh
while they were waiting in line to the
to the envy of other people
um
the pictures that
some of very few here that i've shown
there are many of them showing the
crowds and you can see that there is a
wide range of
economic and social
variety there as well as uh
he
he healed uh people who were brought
from indian reservations
he took in um that didn't take him but
touched
and gave his healing touch to people who
were brought in from the colorado state
hospital mental hospital
there was no one he turned away and it
was very clear that some of the um
more uh
traditional
evangelical
like um ministers were very upset with
this because he did not ask for a
confession of faith he'd heal anyone
they'd say he'll he'll anyway they don't
have to believe in christ
which is true of slaughter
i read that one time that he left
because he was
upset that people were paying to buy
places in line
uh yes
as a matter of fact the the common
notion
that uh
was that
and it's been true for a hundred years
he disappeared because he was angry with
the
kind of materialism the fact that people
were selling
um
uh their
places in line or were paying to have to
be able to move closer up in the line
they'd have small boys they'd pay small
boys you know a few dollars to stand in
line at four o'clock in the morning so
they could come in at two o'clock in the
afternoon and be right there
and it was a it was an idea that this is
why he disappeared um that was that was
current at the time and actually
promoted by his friends
but if he had been offended by that sort
of thing he would have left within a
week
uh he disappeared because he had a
mission to disappear he knew he was
going to walk out of history because he
believed that he would be walking into
a timeless era
it was it's like an end times belief
is there any evidence
that he actually did heal people
yes there is
um
some reporters
uh actually there were many reporters
who
stood to his left when people were
moving
uh
through the line and they would
see what kind of reaction people had
when they when he touched them he never
asked them by the way what they what
they had
uh and the reporters would glom onto
these people uh if they showed that they
had
been able to throw away their crutches
and walk
but one of the most i think
uh telling episodes was of a woman who
had boils all over her face
and as the reporters were interviewing
her those boils disappeared
now
the cause of this you know i i think
i i put myself in a position if i have a
problem
and i need a healer to deal with it and
i'm standing in front of 2 000 people
and i've stood in line for six hours
and i'm
coming up to
a christ-like figure
uh what kind of emotional psychological
psychosomatic effect might that have i
think
that could have been true most of his
most of the people who he
who claimed to have been healed
had
rheumatoid arthritis or aches and pains
that sort of thing although he did claim
to have
there was one dramatic
healing where a 12 year old girl
daughter of the
wyoming national guard
had been blind in one eye and um
after schlatter treated her her father
wrote a note
that
she read having
her hand over the good eye
it was quite dramatic and there were a
few episodes of that
anyone else
anyone want to challenge my hypothesis
i have to ask about the uh the the relic
that was at the uh skeleton the baseball
bat size staff whatever happened to that
um
the
bat the actual the the copper rod that
schlatter had with him
um
he got in denver he had forged in denver
a friend friend paid for it it was
forged in denver and he took it to back
to new mexico and it became widely known
as he was traveling back to new mexico
uh
he used it
uh presumably for exercise and when he
was crossing the border into mexico and
he did go across the border into mexico
despite what
1903 schlatter said
um
he stopped at a ranch and
the cowboys were interested in what the
rod was for and he showed him he took it
and he spun around
and let it fly and he said where the rod
landed in the direction to which it
pointed would be the direction the
father wanted him to go
and he did it once of course appointed
south because he was going to mexico
the rod is an interesting story about
the rod uh long one i'll just shorten it
edgar hewitt who was a well-known
archaeologist southwestern archaeologist
and became the director of the museum of
new mexico
and of the
of the
center for american research
both of them housed in the palace of the
governors in
santa fe
he was on an uh
archaeological exploration in mexico in
in 1906 and he ran across
what was presumed to be the grave
unburied gravesite of francis slaughter
and he learned from his guide as guide
said about
having seen this
man
10 years earlier as a boy
hewitt came to realize that uh this was
francis slaughter and he in the village
of casas grandes he got the rod
he didn't do anything with at the time
but he came back about 17 years later
and then he
offered to pay the village jefe or mayor
money to hire a schoolteacher in
exchange for the rod he took the rod
back and it's now in the museum of new
mexico the new mexico history museum
it was on display for a while
but
now it's gone back to the collection
i won't tell you its significance at
this point
so why don't you think he could heal
himself
of tuberculosis and whatever he was in
that sanatorium for what's that
why do you think he couldn't heal
himself of tuberculosis and
whatever he was in that good samaritan
hospital for you know there are a lot of
a lot of
discrepancies and just
continuities in
spiritual things and
you're saying why can't why couldn't he
heal himself of tb
um
i don't know
i don't know
his wife apparently believed he could
heal himself from of death he could he
could bring himself back to life
but not after he'd been involved hey
mike
the uh bonnie the uh 22 years to uh to
have that sealed and
stay there did you ever learn why that
why it took so long for them to
find it oh
yes um
no i didn't uh there were there were
several in 1945 this was uh
uh in just just when uh the european war
is ending
uh st louis officials found several
unburied bodies um throughout the city
and uh some of them were in warehouses
some of them were you know this one was
in the basement of the funeral home
uh apparently at that time in the 20s
when when some of these bodies were
uh prepared they had a very
powerful embalming fluid of some sort
because slaughter's body as newspaper
accounts had it was very well preserved
uh i think
i think it was just a laxity
in
professional standards and mortuaries
and uh
i certainly don't know why
luverna who actually had arranged to
have her husband's body taken to
miamisburg for burial
never never went back and checked or
never went to his grave but i think i
think what happened was that she may
have been told that it was had been
destroyed somehow accidentally i can't
believe that she would simply walk away
and not
have anything
i mean she went back to him too many
times
i was wondering was there any financial
benefit that he re received that he uh
was uh you know the original slaughter
yes uh did he uh he refused
he refused any offer of money or gifts
and everything and
and when people forced money or gifts on
him
in one case there's a rumor that he took
whatever dollar or whatever it was and
gave it to someone who is
poor
uh he lived on
you know the the um
uh at the hands of people who took care
of him the foxes took care of them in
albuquerque there were people that took
care of him
and um
this is one of the reasons why most
people believe that
second francis slaughter john martin aka
francis slaughter could not have been
the original because
he took coins
uh and he paid his managers and one of
the reasons he was kicked out of
one town was that the
city father said
you know if you have
to
to um
pay managers and
uh why should we be funding that
um
but uh
slaughter was uh the original was um
he he lived as france as saint francis
of assisi would have lived as his name's
sake was
though does that answer your question
yes so in other words he was
sort of lived in the same way that
christ said in other words he never took
money he lived he lived with a vow of
poverty
well uh during this time
uh
how were how
well publicized was this that's the
first time i've ever heard it but that
don't mean too much because i'm not that
world knowledge about
such things though but
i would think that they would been you
know
well known all over the world although
you know
uh
that day and time you know things uh
didn't travel that fast why wasn't he
well known yeah all over you know
the universe
because he walked at him
he he disappeared
this was a conscious decision he made
and when the
news came out of mexico that he was dead
the
book that ada morley had prepared
which was the gospel of new age
was virtually
no
because it's
christ
did
not did not uh return
so i think there was there for a period
of time i will say this i i i didn't
mention them but there were several
other um
there were several other uh imposters
who took his name and i talk about him
in the book
and one of the reasons he may have been
uh
rejected uh was because he's in the
company of several
but
um
uh
the uh
that period of time uh from
uh
early part of the turn of the century to
about 1922 when he died a number of
these people were wandering around the
country and they were creating very
sensational stories
about their acts
and then after the last of them he was
one of the last to die off
during the 30s
almost nothing and it was only after
world war ii that people started writing
again
looking back at francis schlatter and
what happened is that
over a period of um
well from 1945 to 1990 when i started
getting interested in it
there may have been every
five or ten years an article in
newspaper magazine
chapters and books would come out on him
and it'd be a kind of flurry of
excitement and then it would die down
again i think one of the reasons why
that happened
is because
no one who had written about him really
addressed why he disappeared
really looked at what his motives were
even if you discount
the idea that he may have come back
nobody spoke about
the intense
religious
prophetic
ideology that he had and that drove him
and that made him promise
adam morley that he would return
thank you all for attending and let's uh
thank our speaker one more time
thank you very much
thank you
you